Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is going
to be my new thor 4 love and thunder first look
breakdown they just started filming there's a
whole bunch of easter eggs and all this you've
probably been seeing it all over your social media
feeds this morning so if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
this is just the beginning they literally just
started filming the movie recently there's still
so much big marvel stuff coming up this year with
all the marvel disney plus stuff we have falcon
and winter soldier coming up after Wandavision
the loki episodes we'll also see some thor 4 stuff
happening during the loki series as well because
that will connect but just starting with the big
stuff first we'll start with thor's new look here
thor would like you to buy two tickets to the
gun show goman's sleeveless just to show off
all the work he's been doing trying to lose all
that weight since the end of avengers end game
a lot of you longtime comic book fans recognize
that this is basically them doing the thunder
strike costume combined with the jack
kirby costume from the classic thor comics
that doesn't mean that we're actually looking at
thunderstrike here it just means that his costume
is inspired by thunderstrike's costume the costume
designer himself also posted a message just hyping
everything up when this was all dropping this
morning too like i couldn't wait to post this
is just going to be so amazing i had so much fun
working on all these no surprise that everything
looks way crazier than it did during thor
ragnarok even though that itself looked way
crazier than previous thor movies it was meant to
be a reinvention of the thor franchise so this is
just a continuation of that escalating everything
everything turned up to 11. they said it's meant
to feel like an avengers movie like the way
that captain america civil war was avengers 2.5
because there were so many big crossover avengers
characters in it thor 4 is gonna be like avengers
4.5 but if you're not familiar with the thunder
strike character that was eric masterson from
the comics so originally thunder strike was the
name given to eric masterson when he became his
own completely separate version of thor originally
eric masterson was just a construction worker that
thor saved he joined the thor corps he teamed
up with beta ray bill a whole lot had a bunch
of adventures with him i know a lot of people
hoping that beta ray bill shows up in thor for
love and thunder taikowati implied that he was
really down to do that but he didn't confirm that
he was going to be in the movie there were a lot
of corbinite easter eggs during avengers end game
like thanos ship when you go back to the 2014
version of thanos they're assaulting beta ray
bill's home planet during that scene like you
see corbamites wearing these giant suits of armor
so basically they were fighting beta ray bill's
people and during the script pages there were
also a lot of deleted scenes from that moment
too the original script has a whole bunch more
talking about beta ray bill's people during that
scene there was also the beta ray bill easter
egg from thor ragnarok kevin feige revealed that
they had originally planned for him to fight in
the grand masters contest of champions but then
later just decided to cut him out of the movie
when they were in the middle of pre-production
so there was all this work that they had done
putting him in the movie that they had to take out
so that's why you see him on the side of the grand
masters tower because he's meant to be one of the
previous champions so it just wound up being an
easter egg and they're like okay we'll put him
back in another movie when we find a really good
place for him so hopefully that good place winds
up being thor 4. just looking at the pictures from
the set i can't read the logo on his white t-shirt
underneath the jacket but i'm sure there's another
easter egg there it seems bug is meant to be
very metal if we're going for 1980s references
he's still got stormbreaker no big surprise
there it hasn't been that long since the end
of avengers end game when thor 4 picks up based
on the original planned marvel phase 4 timeline
of when all the movies were supposed to come
out before all the virus stuff happened thor 4
was originally supposed to come out this november
2021 so that would have put it around a year and a
half after the end of avengers end game the
bottom half of his costume pure jack kirby
though even though it's meant to be the blue
jeans the pants in the gold wraparound boot
laces are inspired by the classic jack kirby thor
from the original comics his hair's been trimmed
and styled more like a 1980s surfer dude but as
wild as it looks it's still way cleaner in styled
than his hair during avengers end game and his
beard has been trimmed like he has that braid
down the left side of his face but he doesn't
have the dreads anymore those were kind of gross
because he did not get his hair dreaded on purpose
then we have all the new guardians of the galaxy
costume changes and new looks chris pratt wearing
his new costume and his new beard i know a lot of
people are conflicted about the beard i think
it looks fine i'm sure once we get to guardians
of the galaxy 3 which is supposed to shoot later
this year i believe maybe at the end of this year
james gunn will also similarly tune up some of
these costumes and change them just a little bit
but in all these scenes star-lord looks like he's
wearing a tuned up shinier version of his regular
ravager's uniform the red jacket that he always
used to wear in the guardians of the galaxy movies
like now he's got the purple stripes down the
middle instead of dark red all the colors in
general just look tuned up way more saturated
he's got the gold and silver shoulder pads and
the gauntlets on top of his sleeves look way more
hardcore and those shiny silver looking pauldrons
on top of his shoulders the symbols and designs
too if you zoom in enhance on the armored portions
of the costume also seem a lot like the designs on
ego the living planet's costume like the idea is
he's slowly embracing his heritage a little more
or at least in the process of making peace with it
you have to remember the guardians of the galaxy
vol 2 takes place pretty close to the events of
guardians one and then a couple years go by
like a long time goes by before they show up
at the beginning of avengers infinity war so it's
actually been a long time since he met his father
and then wound up killing him seemingly killing
him i know we don't know if he's absolutely dead
because it's actually really really hard to
kill celestials technically he doesn't have
his god-tier celestial cosmic powers anymore since
ego supposedly died the whole thing with that is
that when he was in proximity to ego like when he
was touching ego's surface on the planet he was
functionally immortal and that's when his cosmic
powers were activated once ego died he stopped
being immortal but he still got half celestial
dna which naturally expands his lifespan beyond
a normal humans probably gives him some resilience
too so he's stronger than a normal person he can
still boast about being a god with a little g like
the way the ego said it i'm a god with a little g
thor is a god in the mcu so star-lord can
also make jokes about being one too which is
relevant for the gorr the god butcher story line
with christian bale's character because he's going
around the galaxy literally killing all the gods
that he can find then obviously the next really
big change is craglin finally walking around
wearing yondu's fin his ravager's costume also
seems like it's been tuned up with more highlights
and the color was way more saturated like the
other costumes the way he's walking around here
he's just got that metal piece in his skull so
that he can wear the giant fin the giant fin just
attaches to that metal piece on top the nebula
also looks like she got a similar costume upgrade
from her original ravagers uniform or at least
the last one she was wearing during avengers end
game this one just looks like a more hardcore blue
version of the avengers in-game costume she was
wearing still sleeveless with all the colors way
more saturated even the metal pieces on her look
like they've been tuned up with more highlights
then even though you don't see him in any of these
pictures groot rocket and drax are there as well
like chris pratt posted this video of them heading
to set just a little while ago they were all
on board and if you guys haven't seen it or you
haven't heard vin diesel talking about alpha groot
just two days ago as i'm posting this video
literally just two days he posted an alpha
groot post on his instagram the final boss form
of groot you just have to picture a bigger more
badass looking version of what groot looked like
during the first guardians of the galaxy film so
i don't know if this is vin diesel teasing that
he's going to turn into alpha groot during thor 4
love and thunder or if he's just trying to hype up
guardians 3 because him turning into alpha groot
feels like a really big twist they would save
for guardians of the galaxy vol 3. so maybe just
a slightly larger more evolved version of groot
during thor 4 love and thunder because even though
the guardians are a big deal during thor 4 i'm
not expecting them to be there for the entire film
the other real big thing you probably spotted this
morning in all these pictures were the goats from
the comics they were spotted on set so tooth
nasher and tooth grinder are his goats they're
kind of like cosmic mystical goats that pull his
chariot and carry him across the 10 realms when he
doesn't have access to the bifrost so obviously
the whole thing is the stormbreaker can open
its own bifrost portals anywhere he wants to go so
why would he need the goats unless something winds
up happening during the course of the film that
prevents him from using stormbreaker's bifrost
you can post all the theories you want about
that but the goats themselves tooth nasher and
tooth grinder have shown up during many big thor
comic book story lines including the unworthy thor
which was happening while the jane foster mighty
thor stuff was happening as well but the only
thing that's missing from all this is obviously
christian bale in his gorr the god butcher costume
we don't really know what his look is going to be
like during the film and how close that's going to
be to comic book gorge look because the way his
costume works it is basically the necro sword
creating a costume around him it's sort of like a
living costume the primal symbiote cloaking him in
what seems like billowing darkness i've already
done a big video about gorr the godbutcher's
storyline and what it seems like they're adapting
from the comics for thor 4 love and thunder and
why that's all relevant so i'll put a link for
that down in the description below but if you
spotted any big easter eggs and these pictures
and the costumes that i didn't mention in the
video just write them below in the comments and
everyone just post your general reactions i think
it's probably going to be as crazy as you would
expect it to be i'm so excited to see what's going
on with it there's so much stuff happening this
week my Wandavision episode 5 video is going to
post friday but i do have a brand new Wandavision
fantastic four video that i was working on before
all this stuff dropped that video probably wind up
posting tomorrow there's also a lot of spider-man
3 stuff that tom holland is going to be doing
later this week as well so i'll be doing videos
for that too so make sure you enable alerts for
my channel so you don't miss any of those videos
congratulations andre henderson you're the
giveaway winner for my last big Wandavision video
please email me on the about page of my channel so
i can get your contact details everyone click here
for that crazy Wandavision episode 5 trailer and
click here for my full Wandavision episode 4 video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next video!